this is a production of Cornell
University
good afternoon thank you very much for
the invitation it's a real joy to be
here to actually feel like I'm coming
home at least to my scientific home
where I started and I wanted to sort of
begin would sort of tribute to my
inspirations and science things interior
of my eyes to have the gentleman here
today in the audience that I was an
ethic of college student I thought it
would wanted to get physical therapist
and I went there but I was working in
the biology department part of my job
was actually clean test tubes and clean
fly traps and such and I realized I
really love chemistry more than in love
biology and I thought I really mixed up
my physical therapy ye biology and and
then I met [ __ ] was in ski and he
really sort of inspired me to think
about biochemistry didn't think about
how cells were working in a biochemical
way and so I started doing research
really early on in his laboratory and he
was a tough guy and think really
critically and was very you know
attention to detail make sure you can
communicate your spine as well and he's
to hang out with this guy who I learned
a lot about Steve beer and I used to
walk across the hill and come through
the gorge and come to the lab and meet
up with scientists and go out to lunch
and learn about Chinese cuisine as well
well Christian seems share this vision
of chinese food and also getting
together to talk science and remember
over many hot sour soup that we would be
talking about what erwinia was doing and
so i didn't understand that at all at
the time and so really started my
research spark was really studying fire
of life and this is me back
eighteen eighty eight Richard lab we're
hanging out with another student and
really taught me the essentials of
microbiology and biochemistry to think
about at that time what we are most
interested in it was not necessarily
what how Armenia was causing disease a
fire blight but really what were the
antibiotics produced by another closely
related straining so my research project
is actually how are antibiotics
inhibiting the group that we're winning
and love are pathogen and so doing
simple biochemistry we were able to
actually show that it was inhibiting
amino acid biosynthesis and so for me
that was a real spark you know the walk
away with an answer that was so
satisfying at the time it really gave
you the inspiration to think bigger to
go on and do biochemistry in some other
areas and what I really came back to
after graduate school was thinking about
really then how are the pathogens
manipulating these hosts to cause
disease so I don't have a plant
pathology card but I do have the great
inspiration and plant pathology
background and biochemistry they kind of
launched me to my career so when I went
after i went to brian stas quinces lab
you know I was working on type 3
secretion and try to come up with a
biochemical evidence that that they were
secreted molecules into plant cells I
spent a lot of time as a postdoc trying
to come up with that evidence and when I
left his lab there was still sir the
uncertainty of really one of those
molecules doing how are they causing
disease and so I chose to use a system
that he was using in the lab and
essentially because there was a genetics
on both the a pathogen side end
side so looking at xanthomonas you've
escritorio i will just use it this
strain name mostly in my top was 85 10
this was at the time the genome sequence
train so we had some information about
what was going on but we didn't know
what the effectors were or how the
virulence factors were controlling what
we call bacterial spot disease in tomato
where you see these nice lesions and the
chlorotic out-breath that which is
mostly due to ethylene production and
salicylic acids reduction in these
infected leads and so I thought this
would be a good launch pad to start
thinking about what is effector biology
and I think you all are aware of type
free secretion and that bacteria are are
pumping proteins into plant cells by the
type through secretion system and so
when I started my lab there was a great
enthusiasm about genetic screenings to
find this whole repertoire of proteins
that are being injected into plant cells
and so we use some cool genetic screens
using type 3 signal peptides which I
won't go into but also the work here of
Alan comer and Greg Martin they have
also used whole genome sequencing
bioinformatics and more recently from
Pluto cesses lab using machine learning
approaches to find some you know factors
so using this information we kind of
have a nice collection of the modish
proteins that we calls offs and we
essentially have about 40 plus or minus
I don't look at a lot of different
strains I'm really interested in trying
to get at specific post targets and
understand the mechanisms of action but
also how those targets are playing out
in plant biology what
why are they sensitive nodes of the
packages so what I've been focusing on
are those stands and Mona's proteins
that we call the core group that seem to
be highly conserved among strains and
then I'm also because I'm interested in
signaling and how properties of
virulence can be shared amongst many
diverse pathogens try to focus on a few
of these that have vectors that are in
both animal and plant pathogens so when
we look out in the field for tomato when
we find the isolates through jeff jones
work in florida as well as Brian's task
wits and you look at the collection of
these strains and you've sequence what
the effector what repertoires are one
thing I just wanted to say was that even
if you're looking at some that we have
known about for a while and collected or
ones that are emerging as being real
problematic in the field they had seemed
to have a conserved set and this is just
a subset of them that I'm just
highlighting the names are kind of
irrelevant but the ones that are shown
in orange here are ones that my
laboratory has been working on and
primarily because when you make gene
deletions they have significant effects
on the ability of the bacteria to grow
in the leaves but also their ability to
either produce symptoms or suppress
symptoms so they gave us a good handle
of a starting point of those that seem
to be quite important in the genomes of
these pathogens irregardless where
they're being isolated from in
California or Florida so I wanted to put
this up this is a lot many talks but I
wanted to kind of give it as a
motivation of where I started up and the
types of things that I've been thinking
about so when we think about the
evolution
pathogen interactions we know that a lot
more recently about what are the
receptors that are recognizing the
conserved features on microbes we know a
bit about the signaling pathways for
these basal immune responses or we call
these camp triggers a new responses and
we know that the effectors now some 20
years later or many of these are
suppressing these pathways but we still
don't have a good understanding of what
are all the targets and what are the
activities and then there's plenty of
recognition by resistance genes or NL
ours that are recognizing these
molecules and turning out of our robust
immune system but where I wanted to sort
of add my contribution to the field was
I was not necessarily interested in
identifying initially these are genes I
kind of wanted to ask what we're sort of
those susceptibility knows what was
really the pathogen doing this effector
at this layer so essentially how is it
giving those initial signaling events
for camp triggered immunity and this is
just an overview of a snapshot in case
people who are interested in talking
more deeply about these and in future
talks today but my group is has been
working on a number of these different
effectors i'll tell you about to here
today but i also talked up at geneva
about the natural product discovery
pathway that we've been working on with
a collaborator that's regularly good at
trying to find antimicrobial compounds
implants and then i'm not going to talk
about if you are BST which is one that
appears to be accelerating many proteins
within the cytoplasm and triggering a
very eti or effector trigger response
that i still can't figure out with the
our genius board so i'd love to figure
out how I could find that in tomato and
pepper if I can find some new
collaborators to do so and then this one
is a molecule that I still can't figure
out what its enzymatic function is but
I'm comer road
somewhere yes in this default defense
idea where many times you're hitting it
with a sledge hammer of an effector if
you have too many in there essentially
it's a default of defense and maybe it's
a highly conserved process within the
plant cell that's an under attack and we
have some ideas that we can get probably
paying translation so we're trying to
explore that Avenue okay so I want to
tell you a couple stories today about
two proteins that we've been working on
for a long time the motivation here was
to give the students an idea of how we
get to these targets and then once we
have the hosts target how we're thinking
about studying them and so when we look
at the time course of infection for this
we can either did leaves or we can
infiltrate them and with our bacterium
and what we're looking at is sort of
what's happening over a two-week period
we're looking at symptom development to
the point where we can see spots about
in between days and they 11 we start to
see the lees becoming chlorotic and then
they start to fall apart and this way is
correlating with high bacterial load and
what we were missing early on because a
lot of the work was being done in
arabidopsis looking within a few days to
see how effectors were working we
actually had to stretch that out a
little bit to see our phenotypes and
that's why I point out we're actually
looking in this day 1 day 2 day 8 window
to get the readout of what the signaling
effect was of each molecule that we were
tested and so what I want to point out
is it's a pin although I'm not showing
you the growth curves it's working early
at about date for today six where we can
see the outcome of its effect in
symptoms and zabdiel with a little bit
later downstream in this symptom
development so into
signaling if we go back to that overview
if we think about xanthomonas turning on
Pam triggered immunity we were
essentially thinking that sought then
was probably working early at the early
stages of infection and then top D is
working a bit later what I want to tell
you about today is that we think thats
often has a protein scaffolding activity
that is suppressing pti and zap t is a
really interesting enzyme mimic that
works in the nucleus to repress
transcription I'd like to show you those
data and then the projects that are
coming out of that ok so let's start
with up then we started working on this
with my first graduate student and it
was an unusual protein highly conserved
in almost every day at the motor
straining that we've looked at it seems
to be a core a vector molecule we've
tried to crystallize this protein for
years it seems to have a very fun in a
structured motif it looks like it forms
alpha helical coils and our predictions
and so we predicted maybe it was a
scaffold anchoring on to two proteins we
know it is suppresses PT i will show you
those data but what we found is it forms
of complex with two proteins in the
plant cell and that's schematically
shown here as this receptor like kinase
that although this is a dead kinase it
doesn't have an active site of cosmic
building has a very short lr region
that's extracellular thought Ben seems
to be binding to it very tightly to my
region of this protein at one end and
the other region of this effectors point
binding to a 14-3 three molecule called
TFT one so tomato the 14 three threes
are called tomato 14 threes or two
you may know that from Greg Martin's
work and what we really noticed was that
both of these players if we knock them
out of tomato they're more susceptible
to xanthomonas infection so we see that
this is suppressing it probably by
trapping it in an inactive complex this
is a prediction and we actually want to
test this more carefully and so I won't
go into preliminary data but I just want
to give an overview of the project that
we have a new project in the lab with a
graduate student in drew dustman which
is to actually find this complex at the
plant plasma membrane and so the
prediction is is that if the protein is
trapping this receptor complex who is it
normally interacting with and we don't
believe that this is a receptor that's
recognizing xanthomonas but maybe it's
working with a pattern recognition
receptor we have some phosphatases we
have 14 three threes and we have some
other scaffolds here actually Zoey had
pulled out a protein that had a very
interesting schematic like this and we
were tantalizing it to be 0 PR are but
we have yet to determine if that's true
okay so this essentially we want to
understand what this complexes but it
also opened up the dirt of thinking why
is it trapping 14 three threes because
14 three threes are really important
signaling molecules in organizing
protein complexes also for organizing
and activating or repressing enzyme
activity and so 14 three three proteins
are actually dimers they can be homo
dimers so you can see two molecules here
and they're binding phosphate groups
generally on
cartoons and you'll find that these in
many data sets that people have been
publishing seem to be nodes or targets
of effector proteins and so we got
really inspired by this so thinking one
we don't know very much about 14 three
threes in plant biology or eukaryotic
signaling in general and we don't really
understand why effector molecules with
positive so we'll think about how your
mole proteins on 243 three themselves
and so if you take a look at this
schematic you have 14 33 divers here you
have a client essentially can come in
here often the clients get
phosphorylated by kindnesses 14 three
threes like to bind to phosphorylated
residue so you can see they'll anchor in
here nicely and then what can have
different outcomes of these interactions
one that can bring proteins together and
assemble them for signaling or they can
turn her on and off an enzymatic
activity so we thought hmm this could be
very powerful for a pathogen if you can
rewire how these guys are talking to
host proteins you could affect the main
responses or other pathways so we asked
a simple question our effectors clients
are they actually being you know bound
into the biggest 14 33 complexes to
become activated or are they antagonists
by trying to disrupt their function it
was just a simple question and what we
see from the literature excuse me is
that at least in animal pathogens
pseudomonas aeruginosa there's evidence
that they are actually clients and
here's an example for the effector
called xos this protein actually has a
DP red-hot fossil transferase activity
the detail of that is not important but
it's very important for having cytotoxic
effects in
mice and what it does is it needs to bar
into this complex to become enzymatic
attractive so there's a client sounds
like a chaperone or scaffold for
activation in our work it seems that
it's out then seems to be the antagonist
it's interfering with its activity
because we've shown that T of T 11 of
the isoforms and tomato is required for
pti so we're a conflict which way to go
how are these 14 33 is being co-opted so
we then looked into the literature and I
brought up some of the nice work that's
been done in Greg Martin slab because
he's been actually looking at the 14th
we please in a UTI so my group was
focusing a lot trying to understand how
pti signaling was being abrogated but
then when you take a look at the
Pseudomonas tomato model Greg's nicely
shown the AVR pto in PT oprf signaling
actually requires TFT seven and so it's
requiring the scaffolding protein to
organize my creamy signaling which is
leading to program cell death or
resistance activation and he also showed
that that was required for other
effector out protein combinations so
they seem to be important molecules in
signaling and then we see from other
Arab adopts asst tobacco and rice
systems that you'll find other our genes
like our pw a means to form a scaffold
with a 14 33 tmv the virus is also
requiring 14 33 interactions for
signaling and then Jim leeches group
shown that another isoform actually is
required to turn off resistance and that
was shown in rice so there's a lot of
different ways of these molecules to be
contributing to immunity until we set
out to try to figure this out a little
bit more detail and so this was a
collaboration that we actually did with
greg martin and
and it seems I've been tel aviv
university and zoe so that graduation
day conditions embarrassed but i'm like
her mother i have to embarrass it Oh
Jessie great mark sorry he's there sorry
we know is in figs valve you know call a
connection okay so and then I also
talked about the work that this young
gun Kim has contributed to this project
and so we simply set out for really just
simple aims which was to ask you know
elucidating the roles of these fourteen
three threes in both Heather and Ricky
immunity but also affect your trigger
community we have the hypothesis that
Adam xanthomonas if you had 40 affect
your genes how many of those all a few
are targeting 14 three threes as a new
and so that was a brute force screen to
actually determine if it's just a few is
this an exception or is this actually a
hotspot and then we look at the
phosphorylation state of these affect
your complexes to see it's a
phosphorylation required for binding and
then also what is the requirement of
these complexes during event it's all
just highlight some of this work moving
forward this is something that we're
getting ready to submit and the first
thing that we ask because there's 12
isoforms of 14 three threes and tomato
and they're listed here TFT 1 through 12
and we simply wanted to ask you know
when are these TF cheese express during
infection are some of them induced and
turned on only during immune responses
can we knock them down either using
viruses or stable knock downs and see
what their phenotypes are drink
this tomato interaction and then we also
monitor eti of ethylene responses to see
how this is important in the pathogen
interaction now I should know what we
use a particular strain here this is
different than 85 10 this is a t3 race
of xanthomonas it has this effect regime
avrx game three and the reason why we
use this strain because we have strains
with it and without we want to study the
ability to turn on resistance and if xp3
Hawaii tomato background so turning on
our gene resistance we also have strains
of lack this effective so we can look at
the susceptible interaction okay so what
we see here is that if you look at we
looked at eleven isoforms shown at the
bottom TMT 1 through 11 we're looking
simply at the induction of the mRNA
abundance for these isoforms over time
in tomato and I just wanted to show you
that if you look at Mach and gray I'll
just use this as an example 40ft one if
you have x EV that's turning out pti you
see the 50 expression faces too old and
then you see now you have a larger
induction when you have eti and so
you'll see that where i have it starred
these are showing that we can see
significant increase or induction of
these tMT's gene expression in response
to etim pti but more robust through an
immediate response we were a little bit
happy with this because it kind of
suggested that maybe only some of these
isoforms are involved in the immune
response but actually when we went in
silence them or Staveley knock them down
they all seem to be contributing at some
level to resistance and that that's
unexpected and so you can see this here
it's a little busy but what we're
looking if you folk
day 8 this was a viral knockdown so we
use the TRV vector so this is vector
control to consume the pathogen is not
growing very well here and then all of
the isoforms that we had silenced
actually had at least a log or almost
two logs increase of bacterial tighter
so you can see that they're more
susceptible and they were as susceptible
as other maidens that we know are highly
susceptible or knocked out so that was a
little bit surprising so that means are
all contributing at some level to
resistance and then if you take a look
at the phenotypes in terms of the
pathology what you see in the better
control over time these are over several
days we'll see no symptom development
here or few symptoms at this time point
this is like day four or six but you had
been seen with TFT one now you see when
you knock down this gene you start to
see spot coming up and you can see
various disease symptoms here okay so
the take-home so far for this is really
that all of these TFT isoforms seem to
be contributing to eti and are not
showing you the pti data set so what
we've decided to do is actually try to
construct stable lines where we can
actually knock out a subset of things
and really say can we figure out which
combination of these genes are really
critical for for immunity and the other
thing that we're interested in doing is
we have many tag the lines of these
tMT's because we want to actually purify
the complexes and not do a candidate
approach but actually let the plant tell
you who they are interacting with and
understand how the pathogen are
targeting these TFC protein complexes
and that's future work
so the next question that we try to get
at was which the damn Pomona's effectors
are actually being targeted for
targeting TFT s within the plant cell so
that we did a simple experiment which
was just a complete profile of the 40
effectors that we had we took the 11
isoforms of TF TS and we did
protein-protein interactions and asked
who comes out of that what we found was
it was only a subset but a significant
subset so we found 8 abductors that seem
to mind too many different 14 33
proteins I thought I'd just give you an
example of what that looks like we did
this multiple times but so that's always
kind of surprising because for example
this one protein called a 1 if you look
at the different isoforms in a
two-hybrid you're looking for either
growth or the turning on the blue color
you can see that actually it seems to
have significant finding too many of the
isoforms so not really good specificity
but that might also tell us why many of
these isoforms are required for the
infection condition so we went back we
looked at this list again these are
names you don't have to worry about the
names but what was important was our
initial candidate that interacts with 14
three trees came out so that was a
positive control we also found another
protein if we assess it we have been
working on sup q and then guido has also
found this other protein called zap a
view and keep your eyes peeled for that
because this is the first identification
is shown that this is a kinase its first
bacterial effector kindness that we've
seen it's working in plants and it seems
to be targeting 14 33 complexes that are
required you think for UTI and pti
he has a very nice story on that what we
actually they wanted to do is say do
these things actually interact in planta
this is a lot of yeast interaction
studies so here's where Zoey came in on
the project where she actually was
testing how these proteins were
interacting with tMT's in planta and we
added one more to the list because this
auto activates ed system but it's very
similar in sequences out the one so we
included that in our study and off that
will be the focus over for the rest of
the work so it's only do that she
started out doing a by fluorescence
complementation she took the effector
with a half of the gfp-tagged teach of
the TFT s all of them and with a half of
TFT our gfp-tagged and acid they come
together to get fluorescence and she did
that with all of the effectors we had
identified and all of the 11 I supports
and that's why I think she's a super
graduate soon she actually went to a
group for us and did all of that and but
you can see here is it with the positive
control we have safa and tia to one you
see in these medical cells epidermal
layers you can see that nice cytoplasmic
localization we know that it's off n is
actually interacting near the membrane
so that pattern looks okay what we would
expect give a negative control for
zombie too so it should be dark and we
actually see some fluorescence but not
much and then here's one isoform to ft
10 she could see nicely that it also
looked like it was more membrane
cytoplasmic localized but not
necessarily in the nucleus we have a BRB
s2 which is a protease that France at
scotts is been working a long time on it
came out of our screen but actually it
didn't just show up be validated in
planta and so Zoey being a good student
said I don't really buy this by fact
data I think that maybe you should try
something else to actually confirm these
interactions and so went about it doing
another assay which is doing you may
affinity purification assays so out of
this screen we sort of dropping out a VR
ps2 maybe that's a false positive we
think that these three are definitely
and unfortunately these proteins were
not being very well expressed in our
bypass that seems to be a complication
of the audacity but also probably
because they're unstable proteins and we
haven't figured out a way to get around
that so we tried it a little bit harder
to do the pull downs and see if we keep
yer off' I them so this is taking the
effector putting his tag on it doing
nipple affinity purification so we're
pulling out the effector and asking does
it come along with it TFT and just focus
your eyes here I can walk you through
this we can use a negative control desk
we can purify gusts really well and you
can see that there's no TFT that is hope
you're fine with it AVR bs2 was the one
that we had we could purify it came out
of our screen but we still don't have
any evidence that it interacts with TFG
so again false positive zap need one we
can enrich for it a bit but we can also
pull out that TFT so it's a positive
case e to actually compute Phi that well
and that kind of compliments that by
fact in Dallas
to detect it there you can see it's
purifying tf2 10 here and then zap oh
also poorly Express we can purify some
of it and then see its interactive and
so we were quite satisfied we could at
least see in these pull downs that
application and code precipitation with
tMT's militia one isoform but we have
others that shoots also looked at so the
other thing you can know is every time
she was doing these pull downs we'd see
these hydraulic ulor wage blade species
and it was quite suspicious that maybe
these could be your dick when aidan
molecules that might each of their
instability now we were trying to sort
through what they were and what she
showed was that if you actually take a
look at these you probe with anti
ubiquitin you can see that these TFT
molecules are highly duplicated in the
presence of these effectors and so she
set up the model thinking about perhaps
interaction with the effectors is
promoting them to being liquidated or to
stay adequan ated and that leads
eventually to their degradation and so
one way to shut off the systems just to
get rid of that mold and so what she
then went on to do is then ask well
we're hoping that with any evidence
we're driving sir are they
phosphorylated its phosphorylation
really the mechanism because everything
something together so she purified his
tagged proteins she digested them up and
looked for phosphopeptides did mass spec
and then we actually did a site-directed
mutagenesis to show whether or not it
matters so here's the schematic for
zoffie to zoe nicely mapped and using
some software what might be potential 14
33 phosphorylation sites these are
called 31 sites and the reason why is
because they have a
a serine residue that could be
phosphorylated and what actually she
showed in her mass spec profile was that
she had a number of phosphorylated
residues syrian here for you here etc
but the major hotspots that seemed to be
coming out with the majority of them
with this site as well as your site so
time is running out she wanted to do all
the combinations but she just said I'll
just take a double meeting before I go I
think she was probably interviewing at
that time and so she made this mutation
and this mutation and asked because it
still bind and what she found was
introduced binding significantly ending
completely prevented from binding to the
TFT so here's wild-type effector binding
to this TFT so you can see the nice
biofluorescence complementation and then
you can see here the double mutant it's
not completely gone and can see Reggie's
fluorescence so it appears that
phosphorylation is important to get this
complex together all right so we're left
with this model we have some ideas about
the enzymatic activity of YouTube's I'm
waiting for a student to try those out
but at least from Zoe's work what she
was able to show is that when zoffi to
gets into the plant cell it's
phosphorylated on a number of sites that
allows physical association with at
least one or two isoforms of TF teas and
particularly TFT 10 then we see you
think when a shin of this molecule this
leads to what we believe is
predation but still what we're lefted
know what are the substrates that
natural substrates for these 14 greece
rates so now we have the plants in intel
where we're actually purifying these TFT
complexes to get at the other push
signaling proteins okay then at the end
of the day what's the role of these 14
through these fries in the interaction
and we've had a little bit of trouble
with this because it seems like deleting
one of these 14 three please doesn't
really just seem to inhibit bacterial
throat or enhance bacterial growth
significantly but we did see it a change
in symptom development so we make hole
punches to sample our leaves and what
you can see here hopefully through these
hole punches of sampling this is wild
type gives you this nice chlorosis of
believe we know that the bacteria are
growing really well but what we see is
when we start taking out combinations of
these effector molecules especially in
82 we see that the symptom development
comes much faster and it's within maybe
a day sometimes and you see the leaves
become very erotic it's a sign of
ethylene that we observed or salicylic
acid building up from the leaves and so
we're now looking at how perhaps these
effectors are suppressing the hormone
signaling in the leaf maybe not
affecting tighter so much but def
definitely disease symptom development
and that's ongoing work ok so just to
summarize this part what would I showed
you is that we have a handle a little
bit on some of the host proteins the TFT
isoforms they're required for both pti
and eti there's a small group so not
every effectors target
this node but we condensing
commonalities of these and other
pathogens that have similar orthologues
or homologs and we see that
phosphorylation is important so being
able to anchor into these scaffolding
proteins as a key prerequisite to
suppress their function and now we're
looking at how they're being turned over
in the host cell
so that's sort of a foray into looking
at the early steps of how this protein
is working that's why being a scaffold
but we also discovered the top D working
very late is an enzyme minute and so I
became super fascinated with this
molecule because of the fact when you
take a look at its structure it has what
appears to be eukaryotic features and so
back in the early days in the early
2000s we really didn't understand what
effectors were doing at all and what we
realized right away was that if you take
a look at some interest to see terminus
the c-terminus of this molecule is this
sumo protease and that is a protease
that's working on the ubiquitin path
length specifically the small
ubiquitin-like modifier called sumo and
this modification is often on proteins
and get some dragged into the nucleus or
on transcription factors that control
their activity and so we thought right
away hmm this pathogen molecules not
even clear how about that domain because
bacteria don't have this but somehow
it's wreath using that domain to
manipulate signaling and actually we
could see that it was localized infant
nuclear flow side using benthamiana
assays or stable transgenics and
actually we determine the structure this
was work done in Kinross group to show
that we predicted it to look like this
and actually in fact here's the true
crystal structure of the cysteine
protease so you can see that fold is
really highly identical and what we also
realized is that they had an internal
DNA binding domain and also an ear
repressor motif and this is a repressor
motif it you only find
plant transcriptional repressors you
don't find it in other bacterial
transcription factors and these are
ethylene associated repressor motifs so
we thought perhaps has had all the
equipment to get into the nucleus to
bind DNA there specifically or
nonspecifically maybe interfere with
some repressor complexes and then maybe
work on transcription factors and so
what we set up was really the idea that
it's going in to manipulate host
transcription hitting into the nucleus
cutting off these modifications and
turning over transcription factors at
least that was our dream and it took us
a long time to find those transcription
factors and to show that for one way
they did it was actually going back to
the pathology the timing and the
symptoms were really critical for
getting us there and so what we found
early on when we deleted this molecule
from xanthomonas was that there was a
very interesting phenotype so if you
look at wild-type infection I told you
that ELC xanthomonas will grow to high
titers form these spots and chlorosis if
you just take out this one protein by
day eight or so you see the bacteria are
not growing too high titers but the
leaves really look like they are
symptomatic right but in a sense are
dying and so we were confused by that
for a while because this is not disease
this is actually the host trying to
fight off the pathogen this is
this is the pti and so what we know from
our work we could think perhaps that was
ethylene or hormone signaling and we
quantified epling in these levels to see
in these ladies to see if there was
higher concentration here than there and
it is so when you quantify over a time
course and what you're looking at here
is just leaves that are infected with
magnesium chloride wild-type pathogen or
job you leave and what you're looking
for is over time remember that six to
eight hour window what we see is that
the wild-type pathogen is growing but
it's suppressing epping levels it
continues to keep those ethylene levels
down and they start to creep up around
eight ten but in this OP team you can
you start to see the appearance of
accumulation of ethylene much earlier
and so it really seems that that symptom
development the pathogen is just trying
to keep this down so that it can
maintain replication and spread but
which transcription factors are
controlling this f'ing response there
was not much known about that and so we
went to the leaves and we said let's see
if we can profile for rnas it would give
us an indicator of which transcription
factors might be a potential target and
i won't go through all the detail of
this but we looked at some Martin's
group who is looking at and we looked at
four things that will be the reduced by
xanthomonas or not and so here was one
in particular that I'll point out your
attention to so this is called earth for
we saw that wounding will induce you
cumulation of this transcript and see
the xanthomonas highly induces it and so
the softy mutants so it doesn't really
matter if you have this effect or not
but this is responding to infection or
two
me and we went on to show that that was
in fact a direct target and I won't walk
through this because this is a few years
old but the idea was we actually had a
new target it does clip off sumo off a
particular lie scene by scene 53 and
that simple removal of this molecule
leads to destabilization of this
transcription factor now complete loss
with a reduction enough of a reduction
that it dampens ethylene synthesis and
then athletes and synthesis of earthly
mediated defense gene expression so we
were quite excited about that and at the
same time there were lots of other
people that were interested in other
post targets and so we weren't the only
one that was finding transcription
factors that were being regulated we can
see that there was a myth in arabidopsis
that was under the potential control of
xanthomonas campestris and passengers
and then we also see that there was a
dela transcription factor involved in GA
hormone signaling and iraq offices so
it's hard for me to put my head around
which ones are the key targets and in
those other systems they didn't show
that sumoylation was really tied to the
destabilization or the altering of these
transcription factors so it's possible
that zop d has multiple activities and
multiple targets but at least in the
tomato interaction it seems to be quite
important for suppressing athlean and
suppressing si si but then how do plants
respond to that you know you're putting
something in the in the nucleus to
altered gene expression and so we were
thinking we really want to find
resistances update to understand loads
of actions of how to prepare against it
and we also thought perhaps even though
it's repressing transcription factors it
might also be activated
because you could essentially activate
things to promote infection and we've
seen this in other xanthomonas pepper
interactions where tala factors are
really important for self expansion only
pustules and the symptom development and
pepper and so we've started to think
about how to profile for transcription
factors novel ones and no one had
studied before that might be dynamically
regulated so we found a subset and we
call these D H resulting post induced
jeans and these turn out to be a
particular class of transcription
factors call vhl ages so basic
helix-loop-helix transcription factors
so up here and what we realize these
types of transcription factors are
mostly linked to development and
developmental regulation and so we were
fascinated by that because when you take
a look at this one we see that this one
is increase a thousandfold during
infection and is happening within hours
6 to 12 hours receiving this ramp up
this is for wild-type streams and if you
give rid of all the effectors you see
that it is not induced so this is a
factor to pick you can see another
example the opposite where wild type is
keeping the expression of this gene down
tightly and then you see that this one
is without effectors it is highly
expressed and I won't talk about this
one today but when you knock this one
out we see that it's a negative
regulator of immunity so when plants
laughing dh4 are actually more resistant
to xanthomonas infection so we were
really interested in studying these and
I want to tell you a little bit about
our early work on this there's still
lots of work ahead but getting at close
targets and trying to understand what
they do in the plant cell so why be HLHS
in the literature where we realize more
and more that there's crosstalk between
different pathways whether you're
looking at multiple hormone pathways how
they control each other or if you're
looking at post pathogen interactions
and in the last few years with a hot
topic is really looking at how flagyl in
signaling through fls to cross talks
with the brass misteri pathway and the
point of showing you is that part of the
cross stock is down here in the nucleus
and that's being mediated by pH other
transcription factors and so there was
one question that was left open if
xanthomonas is inducing these
differentially put these be regulators
mediating crosstalk between Brooklyn
development so we explored that idea and
what we found was that we were going to
focus on this one that is highly
conduced and highly regulated in the
direction of up regulation and see what
happens when we knock it down so what we
see here and I wanted to point out the
importance of ZAP d in this process is
that if you actually look early at three
hours we see that this gene is not
turned on if you look at six hours
notice this is mock this is magnesium
chloride transcript is highly induced by
example notice and if you get rid of zop
do you reduce that almost down to 300
this is still a lot this relative
expression still is an induced gene but
most of that induction is do this often
and if you actually get rid of effectors
you see almost about the same result so
this looks like it's a ptin use gene but
also zotti induced and we actually have
developed in a body's field to recognize
this protein and you can see that this
transcript abundance actually correlated
to a protein accumulation so we actually
want to be able to study this protein
and look where what transcripts it's
being regulating within the host cell
and this is relieved you don't see as
much induction of this protein when you
get rid of something so does this matter
do the plants use this dh1 via chili
transcription factor for defense program
or growth program are they an odds are
they working together and what you can
see here is we can silence either stable
eat with digs or Susan E we do them digs
we've done hair pins we've been crisper
all the phenotypes are the same when you
knock out this gene what you can see and
not a closely related one that's not
affected by that that knockout you can
see that the pathogen is able to grow
more so here is Dan Thelonious normal
gets up to 10 to eight we can see
increased growth of the pathogen when we
get rid of this transcription factor we
can also see increased growth of
xanthomonas FD also a log increase of
growth when you get rid of this seems to
be involved in the community it also
seems to be involved in symptom
development because if you look at nine
days before we can see the differential
symptoms rnai lines shown more symptoms
so we were intrigued by that seems to be
a pup involved in immunity but it's also
seemingly involved in growth and so
that's at odds because usually these are
trade-offs so we weren't sure how to
think about it but actually if you look
at it while tech plants are growing
really well these are definitely stunted
you see shorter Internode's we see
increased branching see broader leaves
all right you don't see as much
serration and the symptom development is
quite different on some of these needs
so we also thought well what about below
ground put the blow ground structure of
the roof to be impacted the above ground
vegetation and what we see is really
that's where this transcription factor
seems to be working potentially it's not
really expressed only it's not that much
in stems but highly envious tumors okay
or hide express in words and canoe just
further so what we were thinking about
is maybe this is a root specific
transcription factor playing a role and
the pathogen is reprogramming this in
the leaf and we are really interested in
understanding how is it being
reprogrammed in the leaves and what is
that benefit to the host pathogen your
action and one in sight when we were
looking at increase this route
phenomenal is that being some new
graduate student in my lab has been
actually
below what she had seen is that if you
just sort of quickly put tomato on
filter paper and she does the mass of
these roots versus the amounts here show
them to the silence fine she can see
really a significant reduction in dry
wave of these these roots and she did an
interesting sort of experiment where she
wasn't known if there's an experiment
that she forgot to fertilizer plants and
so if you had helped leaf fertilize
plants you can see a real good growth
differential between the Simon's lines
but when they were not fertilized you
lost them so it suggested it's perhaps
maybe if there is root acquisition of
nutrients you don't see it too much if
you let's say it was a nutrient
transporter right the nutrients are
plentiful wild-type will beat out
silence want but if there's not much
nutrients around the growth differential
would not be the same so we're exploring
the idea that maybe there could be some
sort of nutrient acquisition difference
between these silent linings and those
and then how that is impacted in the
leaves okay so an overview of this is we
kind of have this new transcription
factor family we're looking at we have
pretty good data that shows that this is
triggered in response to heighten the
gellin doesn't matter if you use anthem
owners or pseudomonas so it seems to be
a ptin just jeans and leaves we know
that is out d seems to be turning this
on and you think it's because it's in
the nucleus and it's messing up the
transcription of dh1 and we want to
score the mechanisms of how and look at
night okay all right I just want a
couple more slides and the reason why I
brought this substance might be useful
to the two
community here which was we really
wanted to understand really how these
genes are being expressed and what we
found in the promoter of da chuan was
there some interesting boxes here so
these cysts regulatory elements G boxes
are more linked to developmental
transcription binding sites w boxes are
working boxes and you find the working
transcription factors are sitting there
so it seemed to be a hotspot potentially
whereas Abdi could be altering those
transcription complexes and so what Jean
gan kim did in the lab was he made
transgenic plants with different regions
of this promoter and he nicely showed
that this 1.5 region is really important
for xanthomonas and off the induction
and so it really looks like Jesus
regulatory elements I really the the
link to activation of this gene is
opting dependent manner and importantly
we can show that this is also a protease
dependent which is really important the
simulation system because if you have a
protease dead mutant you can no longer
induce this team so it seems to be that
whatever transcription factors or Co
regulators that are at this promoter are
most likely going to be simulated and
the targets of softie so we set out to
actually do a screen and so part of a
new NSF proposal is actually to look at
all the work piece of tomato to clone
them out to provide the resources so
that you can then use them there's a
hundred 50 or 80 of them those young gun
has pretty much got all of them now
we're going through and testing in a
screen to see which ones are sitting in
the hot spots in these promoters and to
see if they're the target of our
effectors or multiple effectors that
laughs so if those could be resources to
anybody in the lab please contact us
we'd be happy to share those with you
okay so just like the finish for this
part which is that they initially got
into studying zop day because it's a
potent suppressor ethylene had an
interesting new carry out of feature so
it's mimicking host enzymes that
normally regulate processes that control
transcription factors stability we then
use that as a tool to ask what other
things could zop do you be regulating
during the infection and this brought us
to some developmental genes that we
think are playing a role in different
parts of the plan some that are being
controlled by the pathogen and some that
are normally being controlled simply by
development that benefits the growth I
don't think I'll go through that so if I
just said the conclusions and I just
like to finish by just about our
contribution this far was really trying
to understand how gent the mones
effectors like that then use different
fold or enzymatic acid or enzymatic
mimics to regulate the initial immune
responses but now we're very interested
in identifying resistance to both
Southlands opti in different tomato
lines or cup of life I'd like to
acknowledge my group most of this work
was done in collaboration with a number
of books in the lab so Jean King is a
senior research associate in my lab runs
pretty much all of the projects that has
worked now the maida students and Zoe
did all the effector and
and yangsun is working on the th1 in the
root story
using
what's the entering going on take out
the warranty and
yeah that's a French market tomato
branch DF 36 I don't is now process it
right well that's interesting if that
control is the 36th interesting because
processing tomato they don't have a
proponents of fresh markets there that
looks like a friend one we are the
timing it's that tall it should have
black holes and then oh you mean lateral
roots there are our branches what you
find when you girl like entity to
something like that it's explanted this
big out of the pot yeah beside Rachel do
this break what you're seeing in your
sub you plant is actually more of a
typical processing tomato growth habit I
wouldn't consider it so much as Sun tea
as a different form of development with
the processing to okay stated get sum of
any two as long as you know today right
bratz get some of that and while and
grow it and see what happens but most
processing tomatoes are like that and
there is a lot that's known about the
regulation of apical dominance so great
for okay and so if you get that
but a fresh market
you'll see that they will get to
multiple weeks or how to eat before you
get for your plans okay that's a great
suggestion because what we've seen when
we may transgenic arabidopsis is and we
see an effect on the stem formation and
also the emergence of the lateral but
there's also quite a few genes that are
known to affect the way through the
Narrows let's define things like that
eat tomato and so that's three that what
you're doing is affecting development
yeah that's an area that I don't know
much about so appreciate your comments
thank you yeah so I have a lot of softy
questions but good ones I hope so it
sounds like the th th kind of tree my
pops is you have now is that ours off d
is interacting with the transcriptional
factors that are driving this da gama is
not certain of is that it's repressing a
repressor that has all these kind of in
common and it's kind of secondary these
are all kind of secondary genes that are
coming up as you repress that Professor
yeah so the question is sort of which is
the target which is a consequence of
action right and least for the timing of
this this gene comes up very quickly
within three to six hours in terms of at
least that's the earliest transcript
that we can see coming up a thousandfold
so we can't say that that's a primary
event but one of the things I can tell
you is that we look for the alternative
hypothesis which is often times you'll
see upregulation of a transcript if it's
the target so if th one is a target is
off to eat right and you remove that
from the system you essentially could
positively activate transcription of da
chuan to get more of it so we're
exploring that possibility right that it
is the Charlie a target where dh1 is
functioning at multiple times so I think
that's a likely scenario and kind of
deals with this idea that maybe that you
know it's just a reporter for us telling
us which genes are
anyway
news
right so the question is what's
happening to the tighter of xanthomonas
when you look at wild type versus a fee
so if you look in the early stages with
xanthomonas we see a rapid increase two
to four days and then it kind of comes
up to aid levels off where you
saturation if you look at the Abdi it
kind of two to four days it's exactly
the same then when we start to see
things where ethylene is being produced
in salicylic acid that's when we start
to see these Abdi you can't grow anymore
and wild-type keeps going so that
phenotype correlates with reporters that
we are seeing at the portrait stage we
haven't seen bacterial growth
differences for xanthomonas affect our
Moon's earlier than that actually
something that I'm highly interested in
because I can't find a meeting that
breaks that down to say day two and I
don't know what that means
don't drop the g1w 20 the UTB pachinko
TV that can kind of develop that the DZ
is that right so it looks like when you
delete one or more of those we see
chlorosis in the leaf occurring but
vectorial tighter stays the same of
adenosine equate over express that each
left how about the result so I hadn't
done those experiments from we could
certainly do that just putting them in a
more juice promoter in Xanth amonos and
I haven't done those experiments so the
idea to thinking about how that might
suppress symptom development more
effectively during infection is that
what you're thinking about if we use it
although what if mole faster all the way
yes
another person you want have married
there's correlation less than that of
no that's correct that writer I present
itself it's a Lochte when have defect
under the fourteenth we know according
your resources the postings recently
ever have a modifying a multiplier
effect impacted mortifying
so the question is really who's
manipulating who right so you brought up
a nice point that some of these effector
molecules have lipids on them and the
tether them to different compartments
the two that I had talked about one
seems to tether to the memorator one is
not they both seem to be interacting
with 14 three threes in the cytoplasm
and we don't know at this stage who's
controlling because all I can say is
that the 14 three threes are required to
signal for pti and DTI so it suggests
that the effectors are trying to
interfere with the complexes that those
molecules are interacting
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu